so with our discussion about all the
different Robins up to the most
prominent characters being completed
this means we can now finally jump back
into Batman and the quarter of owls now
what we're going to do here is on DC
explained we had the first few videos of
Batman of the court of owls but in truth
I didn't really really like the way
those videos came across they came
across kind of boring and mundane and
sort of repetitive and monotone so I'm
basing to go back and just redo all
these so for those of you guys who have
seen those versions of Batman the court
of owls bear with me for this first
video we're going to cover this whole
series and two videos and so bear with
me here you guys probably going to see a
lot of this stuff but I just keep in
mind this is more for the people who
haven't seen it yet but but that being
said let's just jump up let's jump
straight into the story
now with Batman in the court of owls
what we find is that we pick up with
Batman as he's quelling some kind of a
conflict at Arkham Asylum and so what we
find is that as Batman is trying to
quell this conflict that he's actually
joined by the Joker now what's really
cool here is that Batman and the Joker
seemingly fight together and this serves
two purposes the first is of course to
basically help Batman to equal the odds
against the amount of villains that he's
fighting but the other half is to
demoralize these villains because now
for them
the arch-nemesis of Batman is fighting
alongside Batman so the question becomes
what hope do they really have to stop
this conflict at all to basically
succeed then their uprising and so once
these criminals are demoralized they're
effectively sent back to their places in
Arkham Asylum and things as I guess as
best as they can be go back to some
measure of peace here but what we find
when we jump back to to Wayne Manor is
that this is not in fact the Joker that
this is actually Dick Grayson this was a
huge moment for a lot of Batman fans and
the reason why was because a lot of
people look at this as though it was
possible the Joker was will be making
his debut in the new 52 Batman as part
of court of owls this is really just
more of a teaser on behalf of Scott
Snyder to basically tell us yes the
Joker is still a part of that man
continuity yes he will show up
eventually he's just not here right now
and so what we do is we transition with
Batman and Tim Drake and Damian Wayne
and Dick Grayson as they're getting
ready for some kind of ball because keep
in mind during this time with Batman in
the court of owls this is after Batman
has already come to meet Damian Wayne
when he's fighting alongside is Robin
but it's already after Tim Drake and
Dick Grayson have been Robin is kind of
this in-between period here and so what
we do is to pick up with Bruce Wayne and
he's basically outlining his plans for
what it is that he wants to do with
Gotham City and this is really kind of a
cool concept here because what I think
this does is really tie into Batman as
Bruce Wayne in terms of how Bruce Wayne
is just as effective in helping Gotham
woodies himself as opposed to when he's
Batman but Batman also does the same
thing too but in his own way but
nonetheless what Bruce Wayne basically
says is that brutal is that Gotham is
his home that with Gotham being his home
that he's just as aware of it as anybody
else of the kind of things that have
been seen here and what he does is he
really sort of ties in he really sort of
cites these articles that are being
written
in Emma Gotham magazine or the Gotham
newspaper then what he says is that in
these articles they have a section
called Gotham is where by different
people can write in then they can talk
about what Gotham is and he basically
uses this to say for him
Gotham is a place where people should be
able to call it call it a city home but
do it in a safe place it's a place
whereby those who are poor those who are
unable to make it due to I guess a
smaller financial means should still be
able to succeed and so what he does here
is he basically lays out a plan in
saying that he what he wants to do is I
guess improve on the existing skyline of
Gotham City but he also wants to give
money to the poorer neighborhoods to
give money to the neighborhoods that are
going to basically revitalize the city
and he's letting everybody at this fall
know that he wants them to chip in as
well and so what happens is that we
transition to Bruce Wayne meeting with a
man named Lincoln March now Lincoln
March is a supremely important character
in Batman Quarter vows and we'll
actually find out at the end of court of
owls and knight of owls just how
important Lincoln March is but the idea
here is that Lincoln March is currently
running for mayor of Gotham City and so
basically what happens is that when the
two of them are introduced to each other
by virtue of Vicki Vale that they sort
of began to make plans and talk about
how they're going to get together to
have lunch or breakfast or something
like that and basically see what Bruce
Wayne can do to help to contribute to
the campaign of Lincoln March if what
Lincoln March wants to do falls in line
with the kind of ideologies that Bruce
Wayne has but in the midst of this
conversation between Bruce Wayne and
Lincoln March Bruce Wayne realizes that
Commissioner Gordon seems to be very
tied up at a phone call and overhears
him saying things like stab wounds and
so on and so what happens is Bruce Wayne
detaches himself from Lincoln March and
Vicki Vale he dons his Batman outfit and
he goes to investigate and this is when
we really get into this sort of whodunit
mystery with regards to the the court of
Alice conflict where we find that some
man some unidentified person has
basically been made to stand up and it
has a multitude of puncture wounds with
these small little knives and these
little knobs as they're examined by
Batman have an owl on the I guess on the
health of them indicating that the
possibility exists that The Legend of
the court of owls is true now this is
something the Batman doesn't really buy
in and in fact we'll find up until about
the end of this video that Batman
staunchly believes the court of owls
doesn't exist
and we'll actually find out why he
doesn't believe that but again what
happens here is that that man takes this
time alongside Harvey Bullock to
continue in examining this to continue
trying to find out about this to figure
out what in the world is going on
but what Batman also realizes is that
there's some sort of flammable chemical
that's been used here on the wall and so
what he does as he likes the chemical on
fire and when he sees the chemical
Bernie it spells out the words Bruce
Wayne will die and so this is a very
ominous thing for Bruce Wayne because
the question becomes why would this man
write this and then in turn why would he
die and so again this leaves a lot of
unanswered questions and so what we do
is we find Bruce Wayne traveling back to
Wayne Manor to try to continue
deciphering this even further now one of
the other really interesting concepts
here and this was really a way for Scott
Snyder to sort of make the plot thicker
was that when Batman was analyzing the
body of this man he of course has
collected some evidence with regards to
a scar tissue the man had some skin
under his fingernails and once he had
sent this off to Alfred Alfred had
basically verified that the DNA belonged
to Dick Grayson and so the question was
why is Dick Grayson tied into this more
specifically is it possible Dick Grayson
had killed this man and so what we do is
we jump to Batman as he is I guess
assisting to analyze this corpse
alongside Commissioner Gordon now the
way this is done
Batman has basically installed a device
in the morgue that will allow him to
analyze the body as he's in the Batcave
and so while he's speaking with
Commissioner Gordon we get a little more
information about this man in the sense
that this man had always paid his rent
in cash this man has no identity in
terms of DNA matches in federal or state
databases as far as we can tell this man
doesn't exist what Batman also tells us
as this man has various scarring around
his arms and so on indicating he was
involved in swordplay of some kind and
so what Batman does as he continues to
analyze this as he finds some kind of
artifact on the man's tooth and as he
analyzed that he realizes that it's a
filling but then it has a symbol of an
owl and what this does as a tips
Commissioner Gordon off and Commissioner
Gordon begins to give us some
information about the court of owls and
what we learn is that what the court of
owls this is supposedly some kind of
shady group that has been existing
within Gotham City for hundreds of years
and there's even Nursery Rhymes based on
the court of owls in the sense that
those individuals who
know about the court of owls would most
likely be sent since I guess after by
the town who would presumably kill these
people if they were to ever talk about
the court of owls but again these are
really just sort of childhood Nursery
Rhymes
the Batman doesn't put any stock into
and this for me is a very big moment for
Batman because what it tells us is that
Batman perceives that he knows
everything about Gotham City there's
nothing he doesn't know and I would go
as far as to say despite his intellect
his finest capabilities this is a very
incredible demonstration of arrogance
about Batman to say that there's nothing
in the city he's unaware of but as we'll
learn that he's very much wrong in this
endeavor and so what happens that his
Batman is analyzing this body he's
joined by Dick Grayson and Batman begins
to ask Dick Grayson why it is this man
had Dick Grayson skin under his
fingernails and what Dick Grayson does
is he tells us exactly what had taken
place with this man that for some reason
or another that this man had basically
contacted Dick Grayson that in fact he
had basically grabbed at Grayson and
that while Dick Grayson this man were
scuffling with one another the security
had pulled this man away but in the
process the man had scratched Dick
Grayson and as a result this was how the
skin of Dick Grayson ended up under this
man's fingernails but in addition to
this this man had also began uttering
things like they are coming and so on
indicating that some group is coming
after Dick Grayson but Dick Grayson
really has no idea who this group is or
why this group would be doing that and
so what we do here is we see that his
Batman begins to conclude this this
investigation with this course as he
begins to conclude this investigation
with both Dick Grayson and Jim Gordon
that we see that we switch to the old
Wayne Manor building and again what we
find is that Bruce Wayne is continuing
to meet with Lincoln March here and it
seems as though what it isn't linked in
March is spinning - Bruce Wayne what is
it he's saying - Bruce Wayne is very
very enticing in the sense that his
ideologies are almost in line with Bruce
Wayne that Gotham has been failing for
quite some time it's really been seeking
into a cesspool and so as a result what
he wants to do is basically help Bruce
Wayne revitalize Gotham and so what
Bruce Wayne does is he tells likud March
that if he has the support of Bruce
Wayne that in the end he'll gain the
support of a multitude of other people
who can contribute financially to his
campaign and almost guarantee his
position as mayor but what we also do is
we see Lincoln March beginning to
identify with Bruce
plane and this is very very important
I'd like you guys to keep this in the
back of your head because what we'll
find is that this segment will actually
tie in much later on in the court night
of owls and give us an idea of what's
been going on with Lincoln March but
what Lincoln says is that he and a lot
of ways can identify directly with with
Bruce Wayne in the sense that Bruce
Wayne had lost his parents at a very
young age and that Lincoln March had as
well but Lincoln March focuses more on
as mother than anything else and what he
says is that he doesn't remember a whole
lot about her he doesn't recall a whole
lot about her things that he really can
t remember her face anymore
but more so than that the one thing that
he can remember is a pen that she had
this sort of heart-shaped pen and she
always Ward and that when the action had
occurred that led to his mother dying
that is he was being taken away that he
remembered looking back and seeing the
pen that there was no injury on this pen
there was nothing wrong with this pen
and this again there's a very important
concept that I'd like you to keep in
mind but as the two of them are talking
as the two of them are conversing we
find that Batman and in Lincoln March I
guess Bruce Wayne and Lincoln March are
ambushed by some individual who's
dressed up in some kind of assassin gear
and looks very much like an owl and so
what happens is that Lincoln March is
attacked by this man he's assaulted with
a dagger of sorts and then the man goes
after Bruce Wayne telling him that he's
been sentenced to die by the court of
owls and so what happens is as Bruce
Wayne and the Talon are fighting that
the town attacks Bruce Wayne and Bruce
Wayne is knocked out of Wayne Tower from
the height of the building and so as the
two of them are falling down the two of
them continue to fight with one another
and Bruce Wayne begins to give us this
monologue and telling us that as the two
of them are going at it that when the
tower was built that there were
different statues built around the tower
itself at the top which were designed to
serve a couple purposes some of them
superstition and some of them practical
but one of the purposes or I guess one
of these these things were designed in
such a way to where it was lowered down
from the others and so what happens is
Bruce Wayne lands on this 13th guardian
as he does he defines it and this
individual who presumably is the Talon
falls presumably to his death and lands
on a car now from here what we do is we
jump to a little bit of history with
regards to Gotham City more specifically
with the Wayne's
and what we do is we pick up with a man
named Allen Wayne
and Alan Wayne is again sort of running
for his life and seems to have lost his
mind entirely in the sense that back in
this time in 1922 in a very early Gotham
he wasn't the police and is rambling on
about how there are I guess
owls that are coming after him about how
the thirteenth hour is near indicating
that the end of his life is coming and
so what happens is that while the police
are trying to figure out what to do with
him their initial idea is that perhaps
they should take him in perhaps they
should inform somebody of what it is
that's going on to take him downtown
basically but the idea here is that if
they take Alan Wayne downtown the most
prominent member in Gotham at the time
and if they somehow label him as being
an insane person this in turn will
basically I guess tarnish the name of
Gotham or tarnish the name of the
Wayne's and its Hearn possibly ruin the
career of the police and so again as
they're continuing to discuss this we
find that Alan Wayne simply just
vanishes into a sewer we have no real
idea what had happened to him or where
it is that he had gone in addition we
pick it with Batman once he gets back to
Wayne Manor and begins conversing with
Alfred and what happens as the two of
them are talking is they begin to get
into a discussion about the court of
owls and what Batman says here is that
this person who attacked and seems to be
operating under the alias of the Talon
which again seems to be the as far as
Alfred or Batman is concerned a way for
this person to sort of instill fear by
stealing the moniker of the Talon and so
what Alfred does is he gives us some
explanation about Allan Wayne he tells
us about what it is it had happened over
the course of his life in the sense that
when Allan Wayne had grown older over
his life he had become obsessed with the
idea of owls and had become obsessed
with the idea that the owls were
roosting in in various buildings and
they had been roosting in the home of
Allan Wayne and so while people are
considered Allan Wayne to be entirely
insane and the current time Batman
thinks there may have been some
legitimacy to this but he also sort of I
guess dispels this idea and the fact
that as far as he's concerned again
there really is no court of owls there's
really no way this court of owls could
exist here and so what happens is we
pick up with Bruce Wayne as he's again
gone this outfit of Batman and he gives
us some really really really cool inside
here and what he tells us is that the
idea of the number thirteen was
considered to be a prominent part of
Allen Williams life he was a very
superstitious person and so when the
buildings of a
of Gotham were built they were built in
such a way to where as far as the
superstition of the number 13 goes that
a small space of sorts just small enough
to basically house a single apartment
was built between the 12th and the 14th
floors and the way this was designed to
do or I guess what this was designed to
do was to basically house the bad luck
of number thirteen within this this
small space so it couldn't actually
spread out to anybody else and so what
he does is he lands in one of the
buildings and he cuts open a hole in the
on the 14th floor and when he falls
through he ends up in the small section
of the 13th floor and he finds what
appears to be all these different things
which belong to the town or somebody who
is identifying this outfit but what he
also finds is what appears to be a
portrait dating all the way back to 1891
of the court of owls and so what he does
is he contacts Alfred and he asked him
about all the buildings that have been
improved upon using the the fund that
was established an Allen Wayne's name
and so once he gets his list of
buildings he begins going through all of
them and every single building that has
any kind of a storage space for the 13th
floor instead of being just an empty
vacant spot houses all these different
artifacts and all these different items
involving the court of owls and so what
happens is that as Batman is
investigating this last place the place
that was established in 2006 which
presumably has the Talon in his most
recent form we find there's some kind of
an explosion and in the presumably chaos
Batman seems to have been killed with
that being said we're going to go ahead
and bring this video to an end have a
look crazy cliffhanger to leave it on
we're gonna go ahead and bring it to an
end I hope you guys enjoyed it if you
did let me know and I will catch you
guys later peace be sure to follow me on
Twitter there you can keep up with all
the updates from comics explained and
talk to me directly
you can't deal
Oh